[Music]
make your family proud
it's time to meet the madrigal family
and more many of the performers dove
into acting for the very first time with
this movie and tons of them recorded in
isolation from all over the world we're
checking out 12 of the performers behind
the voices of encanto
one of the amazing madrigals
i'm the voice of mirabelle from walt
disney animation studios in canton
stephanie beatrice blows her performance
out of the water doing her colombian
father proud i'm part of the amazing
madrigal the actress has been on a roll
from playing rosa diaz in brooklyn
nine-nine to countless other projects
she's been taking on including plenty of
time in the booth recording voices for
bob's burgers she did have her fair
share of flubs in the booth for this one
though let's do it again please thank
you a lifelong lover of disney taking on
this role was a literal dream come true
i will save the miracle
now she can help inspire other people to
believe that anything is possible i'm
sure there's behind the scenes footage
to show how much fun i was having
stephanie yes
even though they worked together from a
distance stephanie's performance still
got lin-manuel miranda right in the
feels i don't know i hope i did it
justice oh no worries about that anyone
that sees the movie knows that she
absolutely did i found his last vision
the family's in trouble the magic is
dying the house is breaking we skipped
is fading and i think it's all because
of
me
make way abuela is coming through disney
is an american company but that didn't
mean maria cecilia botero had to leave
colombia to do one of their movies with
the pandemic happening over the course
of recording the actress stayed in her
home country working with the creative
team on zoom they miracled
with them
let's eat with her
[Music]
they may never have shared the room
together but that didn't stop potero
from having an amazing collaboration
with the team even when she thought she
was flubbing she was nailing it i'm
talking too fast
no that sounds great
we know we don't talk about bruno but
we gotta talk about bruno john leguizamo
is one of the busiest actors around but
a packed schedule wasn't gonna stop him
from making room for encanto after all i
made the sparkle his charm is like no
other the performance that comes through
his character on screen really makes an
impact and from the looks of the booth
footage he didn't hold back a thing to
make the candle break you have to
embrace her embrace and um
any chance of some bruno shorts coming
at us in the future disney hey if you
save the encounter come visit need a
sweet voice encanto has you covered
valderrama is no stranger to voice over
or to disney he played gaxton and onward
and is the manny of handymanny you must
be very excited he also happens to have
been the face behind fez in that 70s
show this role meant the world to him
especially because his own mother is
colombian
this part was all heart she's right i'm
more
on screen or behind the mic this actress
works it from jane the virgin to
countless spanish television shows and
movies the colombian actress has made
waves in the industry and really made
her mark in the disney world as julieta
what i think
is that today was very hard for you
celebrating the premiere was super
special since she was one of the many
actors who recorded from their homes
never actually meeting everyone in
person
so so happy because it's the first time
that we meet we didn't really
get to know each other
number six
she goes by dolores in encanto but she
is also known as the reggaeton princess
she didn't get one while she's a
successful singer this is her first time
diving into the acting business i just
felt like a tiger like i seized the
moment luckily it happened because when
she first sent in her audition tape it
went straight to spam the next morning
we had we hadn't heard back and i was
like okay maybe we should write
something and then everything was sorted
but then tragedy struck when arasa found
herself unable to move struggling with
some side effects from having kovid19
but then she got word that disney wanted
her to play dolores
and the day she finally got to get to
work well there was no holding back i
was like all right like give it to me
and then i just let it rip in one take
and he was like we're done and i was
like yes
we have a feeling this won't be her last
voiceover role
that's like the cherry on top of a dream
hair toss check her nails isabella's
ready from jane the virgin to orange is
the new black guerrero never fails to
show just how wide her range is she was
embodying every single part of isabella
while recording her dialogue at the
booth when she got her chance to sing
well she was just a little excited about
it i've been like waking up with the
song and going to sleep with it even
when she wasn't performing the songs she
just couldn't stay away from bringing
those musical vibes making the movie
that much better
[Music]
i don't know if you wanted me to sing
one of the highlights for the american
colombian actress was of course getting
to work with lin-manuel miranda even if
it was via screen always make those
questions into questions they didn't
need to be together to bring the magic
i just made something unexpected
number eight
she's feisty and she's fierce she's
luisa with the super strength encounter
marked the american actress's very first
voiceover role while she recorded the
whole thing remotely during the pandemic
she did get to spend some time in person
with the creative team off the bat i
actually had the incredible opportunity
to audition in person in la right before
the pandemic hit which was pretty wild
her performance made luisa a total
standout in the movie especially that
glorious song of hers here's hoping
we'll be hearing a lot more about this
fab actress soon sweet thank you
if you've ever been to colombia you've
probably heard about this guy not just
felix of the madrigals but moro castillo
as well since he's an extremely
successful and popular singer and actor
and trombonist talk about being
multi-talented he brought all the good
vibes to the booth
it was a celebration during the making
and the launch especially after spending
a very long time recording everything to
get it just right uh we are working from
uh
for like a year maybe maybe a year
make way we've got a star coming through
young as he may look juan castano has
already been working for over a decade
making a name for himself on screen and
hit shows like tales of the city and
what if he really made his first voice
overall count in encanto stealing every
scene he's in and very obviously having
a blast in that booth as gift ceremony
was a bummer
what fun is bringing the 60th animated
disney movie to life without some joking
around in laughter
look no further maluma shot to fame as a
singer with that oh so sweet voice of
his and the way he feels about the music
of his country well it just makes us
adore him even more columbia music is
special because we do it with our heart
you know we do it with love considering
how much fun he had and how much magic
he brings to the movie we wouldn't be
surprised if he voices some more
characters soon
she's a legend no big deal rose portillo
has been acting since the 1970s
starring in countless tv shows and films
over the years she gained a whole new
group of fans from her performance as
senora guzman that there weren't
problems with the monthly magic
this was one stellar time making the
majority of the film during a pandemic
is no small feat either but it didn't
take away from the magic at all it's
really hard to tell that some of these
performers have never acted before
because the quality is high and these
characters have sung and danced their
way right into our hearts which
character is your favorite